the first trailer for glass just dropped
reuniting and breakables bruce willis
and samuel l.jackson and adding splits
james mcavoy to the comic book mix
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm breaking down the glass
trailer for intriguing details and
connections you might have missed it's
amazing to meet you
notice the purple glow that flashes over
the universal logo towards the start of
the trailer
that's a nice not to the color that's
been associated with our titular
character glass since he first appeared
in the movie unbreakable back in 2000
and when we see Elijah aka mr. glass
Kevin Wendell Crum and David Dunn
together in this scene each of them is
wearing their signature color from
either unbreakable or split glasses in
purple Dunn is in green albeit a very
pale one and Kevin is in yellow these
colors are also reflected in the design
of the villain and superhero in the
first comic book that a young girl I
drew was given by his mother in
unbreakable and this color scheme is
also evident in the comic book store
later in the trailer where the hero
section is bathed in green light and
where the villains section is in purple
as we know from split kevin has 23
separate personalities which was shown
on his computer plus a twenty fourth
superhuman alter-ego known as the beast
and Sarah Paulsen's psychiatrist
character dr. Ellie staple already
understands this I have no question
there are two dozen identities that live
in that body with you from the trailer
it looks like we'll get to see at least
three more of Kevin's identities there's
Mary Reynolds a spanish-speaking
personality and maybe a prankster type
American guy notice also the multiple
toothbrushes provided for Kevin one for
each of his personalities which is a
subtle callback to the 23 to 79
questioning is your belief that you are
something more than human now that's an
interesting parallel between dr. staple
and Kevin's former psychiatrist dr.
Fletcher he also had her doubts about
whether the beast was real or not I
don't understand
it can't be real there must be limits to
what a human being can become of course
we know that the beast was very real and
split and it seems like mr. glass
probably knows that too or perhaps he
even had something to do with Kevin's
backstory there's an interesting shot of
glass looking at a comic book where a
character is prising open steel bars in
a shot that's very reminiscent of the
end of split where the beasts tried to
break into the cage that Casey had
locked herself into the two wounds on
Kevin's torso is another nice detail
calling back to that encounter when
Casey tried to shoot the Beast at
point-blank range and mr. glass actually
refers to that moment from split with
this line and yet some of us still don't
die with bullets glass is clearly
fascinating with the beast and wants to
meet him man meet the Beast I hope for
your sake that he likes you that sounds
like the bear gasps teaming up I wonder
if by bad guys glass is not just
referring to himself and the Beast
joining forces but he's actually also
referring to the Horde which is the name
the news report gave to Kevin at the end
of split because of his many
personalities he's being called the horn
remember also an unbreakable that glass
was interested in a comic book called
century man and the coalition of evil
and interestingly some of that cover
appears in the comic-con poster art for
glass I have a feeling that mr. glass is
planning to manipulate Kevin for his own
ends think back to what his mother said
in unbreakable there's the soldier woman
who fights the hero with his hands and
then there's the real threat that
brilliant and evil archenemy who fights
the hero with his
I think glass sees himself as the
brilliant genius and Kevin as a useful
powerful villain to serve his needs no
way also key to the story is going to be
Casey who seems to be able to connect
with Kevin it seems by a hedwig in this
scene similar to how she didn't split
getting him to take her to the window in
his room and give her his walkie-talkie
and returning from unbreakable a David
Dunn son and Elijah Prince's mother who
could both hole Clues will be keys to
understanding how Dunn and glass
acquired their powers and weaknesses it
looks like this movie will also revisit
Dunn's kryptonite water with him getting
attacked by the Beast possibly knocking
him into a small water tower behind him
here the shot of the Beast knocking done
out of a building window also reminds me
of unbreakable
when Dunn was pushed over a balcony into
a swimming pool also noticed that dr.
staple looks to be rest being done by
pulling him out of water in this other
shot what do we call you sir
first name mister last name this is a
rather epic way to end the trailer and I
don't know about you but those final
lines gave me vibes of Sidney Poitier in
the 1960s oscar-winning film in the heat
of the night what did they call you up
there they call me mr. Tibbs so what do
you think about the glass trailer and
did you spot any other interesting
details or do you have any theories
about the movie leave me your comments
and thoughts below and if you enjoyed
this a like is really appreciated
tapleft to check out more of my comic
book movie videos or tap write for
another video you're sure to like thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers